- Walk me through like this feud that you've
got with Dana White. Who started it?
Who's gonna end it? How does it end?
I want, I want to know
what's going on with that.
- It all started back in 2000.
It started when I was fighting Ben Askren.
And he said on a podcast,
on Mike Tyson's podcast,
that he would bet a million dollars
that I would lose to Ben Askren.
So that's where it all
started. And he then
got Ben Askren to go and train
with Freddie Roach,
who's like a legendary boxing trainer
and was trying to, you know,
do all this stuff to get him to win.
And we just started
going back and forth, and
I beat Ben in a minute and 59 seconds.
And Dana was just silent.
He couldn't believe it.
Of course, then his only thing is
so that he doesn't look like an idiot.
It's to, you know, insinuate
that these are rigged. Insinuate that
these fights aren't real.
He's doing anything to save his ass
because I'm beating all of the guys
that were dominant in his league, the UFC.
And so it's a bad look for his whole
entire company and organization.
So, you know, he's smart.
He's a smart guy, super smart guy,
and he's going to do anything
he can to discredit me.
But, again, it just
makes the numbers go up, and
it is what it is.
- Have you had any one on
one conversation with Dana?
- I don't think so. No, I have not.
- So all of this is just podcast, podcast.
I say this, you say that.
Where's my money?
- Yeah.
- OK.
- And now it's fun for me.
- Yeah.
- Like, because I see how mad he gets.
- And I'm just, like... That's what
people don't get. Like when I'm trolling,
I'm having— I'm just laughing.
Like, I'll just be sitting there
in my room on my phone just laughing
at like all the jokes I'm making, and I see
how pissed off it makes these meatheads.
I call them, like, meatheads
because they don't know anything
or any other emotion than to just,
like, get angry and, like, react.
So it's like they're my puppets,
and I just get them to, like, react,
however exactly I want them to.
And I'm just always one step ahead.
So for me, it's just fun.
Like, I see him get all mad
and say all this stuff.
And, like, I just laugh at it
because he's an old, fat, miserable man,
you know? So, it's just funny, man.
- How does the feud end?
How do you want the feud to end?
- Man.
I would say a sword battle to the death
would be pretty dope.
- You versus Dana White.
- Pay per view.
- Sword battle to the death.
- No, I mean, who knows if it ends.
It might never end.
- Mmhmm.
- I think eventually he's gonna
have to do business with me
and let his UFC champions
come over and box me. You know,
just like he did with Conor and Floyd.
Cuz at the end of the day,
money talks, and
he's a smart guy who wants
to make money for the UFC.
So he's gonna let a champion come over
and we'll probably do a co-promotion
where I'm fighting Conor,
Kamaru Usman or whoever it is.